the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon video
in this video i will show you what
amelia clark said about the new game of
thrones successor show house of the
dragon
as well as how she feels about the game
of thrones finale
now that it's been a few years since it
ended this video will be short and sweet
so let's jump right into it
during a recent interview with the
hollywood reporter emilia clarke was
asked if it was bizarre to see the new
targaryens already
as you all know emilia was once a member
of house targaryen herself
she said it's very surreal i mean i've
been ready for this because miguel
sapochnick who is one of the showrunners
is a really dear friend of mine so i've
been chatting to him about it for a
while
she knew about it happening before it
was officially announced
but yeah it's crazy those photos came
out and i was like whoa
i was on my own last time i didn't know
i had pals
i could have had a bunch of friends to
hang out with but yes it's mildly
surreal to be seeing all of that again
but good luck on them is what i would
say i really mean that
amelia was then asked about her blonde
hair during her days on game of thrones
the interviewer said so you bleached
your hair blonde for the final season
is that something you'd recommend to the
house of the dragon actors
or is it not worth the damage amelia
said no
it is not worth it i'm speaking from the
other side and it's not worth it
i literally cut off all my hair because
i killed it with a load of bleach
if you like your hair keep it that
natural color that goes for everyone
alright now i want to show you what she
said about her ending on game of thrones
now that she's had a few years to look
back on it
i know i am always interested in hearing
what the actors have to say about their
days on the show
ahead of the final season i remember you
talking about the long walks you would
go on as she tried to reconcile daenerys
conclusion
now that you're a few years removed from
the series finale
have you been able to make peace with
everything emilia said i really have
i really really really have i think
it'll take me to my 90s to be able to
objectively
see what game of thrones was because
there's just too much of me in it
i have too many emotional reactions for
what amelia herself
was experiencing at that moment in time
when we were filming it
you know what i mean i watch a scene and
i go oh
that was when such and such happened
which you didn't see on screen
and i think there's something timely
about the spin-offs and the continuation
of the game of thrones story coming out
now
i look at it and i'm like wow yeah so i
see it with only peace
i'm still friends with people from the
show and i know i will be friends with
these people until the day that i die
so it's had a lasting impact on my life
and it starts to become like hey guys
remember when we were in college
hey remember the fourth grade you start
to see it from that perspective
daenerys has a part of my heart she is
in there and i'll never forget
i can't remember who i was talking to
but they were like oh my god when you
say she
you're talking about daenerys and i was
like yeah because she's a whole person
she's got her own life that i explore so
i think that there's the show
the impact of the show the impact of the
show on me
personally and professionally and the
zeitgeistiness of it
and then there's daenerys so that's my
own private little space that i don't
need to make peace with because it's
just a beautiful memory
it's just a beautiful memory
[Music]
you